[Music]
[Applause]
this year we teamed up with sourcewell
to bring you some of the best industry
insights from current top performers and
successful recruitment entrepreneurs
across the
country tonight is no different as we
host our penultimate live podcast event
of the year in Bristol for the very
first time we're going to be joined by
Alicia teagle from sr2 Nigel Roman from
Opus Talent Solutions and Guy Walker
from talener group we're going to be
discussing the key insights from 2023
what have been the biggest challenges
what have they learned how have they
navigated the challenging Market that
we've all faced this year and more then
we'll be covering winning strategies for
2024 what are they remaining laser
focused on going into next year what
lessons are they taking into 2024 and
what are they communicating with their
team team to ensure they have a
successful
2024 no fluff no egos just honest advice
real experiences and genuine insights so
now it's time for our last event of the
year so please put your hands together
and welcome to the stage he Mazo Guy
Walker Alicia tle and Nigel
Romano
I feel very famous right
now hello testing T all good can you
hear us hear us at the back yeah awesome
um thank you all for being here really
excited to um put on this event tonight
obviously first one in Bristol so um
together with the panel we're going to
try and keep it as honest as possible um
as you just saw in the video there we're
going to talk about this year we're
going to talk about you know what do
these guys have in mind going into next
year and then we've got about 20 30
minutes of live Q&A as well the way that
we're going to be doing it is we're not
going to run around with like a
microphone I think that'd be too chaotic
so we're going to use a Tech Tool which
probably means we're going to have a
problem with it but like we'll
you know we'll go with it a lot of you
submitted questions I've got those up my
seve so you know if you just play out
with me hopefully uh it will work and we
can get some good questions answered um
so I guess before we start let's just do
some brief intros n want to come to you
first uh if that's okay do you want to
do a brief intro um to those that may
not know who you are and then Elicia
will come to you next hello everyone uh
great to be here my name is Nigel Roman
I am the CEO of opra Talent Solutions we
are a tech and energy uh business we've
been going for 15 years started in
Bristol um and we've got lots of offices
around the world so I'm really looking
forward to speaking at this Bristal
event you thanks
Mom evening everyone um I'm Alicia
teagle co-founder of sr2 socially
responsible recruitment plus many other
things that I'm sure we'll get into uh
Bristol HQ big up Bristol uh second
London office opened in Jan 2021 and
we've just opened our Austin office so
excited to dig into challenges successes
the pain that we've all been through
this
year uh I'm Guy Walker from talena group
started just under six years ago similar
time to SL2 actually um headquartered in
Bristol and we operate in various
different sectors under V various
different brands awesome um so where
we're going to start this is as I said
in that video we thought the perfect
place to start is just to have a bit of
sort of honest reflection with all of
you and we're going to find out from
these three what have been some of the
biggest challenges this year um cuz some
of them uh that they share maybe all of
you have experienced this year as well I
think you know we wanted to with this
being the first event in Bristol what I
definitely experienced I've been calling
it there's quite a lot of Bristol beef
these guys have hated that but um I
think like people being sort of dubious
about 100 Recruiters in the same room
how's that going to be these guys want
to be as honest as possible they want to
you know hopefully give you as much
value and insight as possible so so we
thought we start this by sharing um how
these guys did last year compared to
this year from a gross profit standpoint
um so just to Define gross profit um
that is the amount of money left after
they paid contractors and the amount of
permanent placement fees just to be
super clear so for sr2 um last year 2022
their GP was 8 million this year it's
six for Opus it was 48 million and this
year is 38 and then talena group um last
year was 5.9 um and they're on track to
do
8.5 um I think obviously worth
mentioning um sr2 mainly Tech right
obviously different locations Opus Tech
but then you also have a renault's brand
which we'll talk about because that's
been a real growth era for you guys this
year and then Talent your group about 70
80% for guys education but then he has
two other brands um that do sales
marketing digital uh sales marketing
digital Finance Rena engineering
sustainability construction so a bit
more diverse over there so um where
where we'll start is let's think about
some of these challenges um in terms of
this year so Alicia I'm going to come to
you first that's the okay so I think
what you shared with me was one of your
biggest challenges this year was the
team having a true 360 recruitment
mindset so do you want to just share
with us like what that means how that
sort of manifested just talk to us a bit
about that and then we'll we'll go from
there yeah and I think one thing that I
wanted to say before com to this room
like I think all of us age we're not we
haven't got this magic pill to say this
is how to be successful like this year
has been so hard but we're just a tech
recruitment company we haven't
Diversified and we've really stuck in
our Lane in terms of what we're good at
um and I think that 360 mindset has been
a huge challenge because of the last
couple of years it's been a gold mine
for recruiters um where if we strip it
real back there's probably 20% of the
business that could actually pull jobs
um and the rest of them were a delivery
team getting paid 360 comps um decent so
that's again transparent that that's
what it was and we've obviously lost a
lot of people this year through various
different reasons a lot of them going
traveling because of the offset of onset
offset of of coid um and them having
plans and I think that really Sha light
on people who weren't capable of pulling
jobs on what recruitment was when I
started 10 years ago like that was what
recruitment really was is picking up the
phone picking up the Yellow Pages if
that was still a thing I mean I used to
have a a full Dino Jack posted about
having the folder of CVS you used to
write on and it's just about yeah what
real sales is but equally adapting to
this new world which is full of
Technology full of different tools being
creative doing indirect selling and just
people aren't capable to do that which
is absolutely fine um so how how did
just on so how did that mindset show up
so like what did that actually sound
like was you speaking to people like
right this week this is your BD plan and
then every week you got to the end of
the week and going Alicia I'm so sorry I
didn't get around to doing BD I was
filling these jobs like what what did
that actually look like what kept coming
up from the management standpoint that
meant BD wasn't being done like what did
that actually look like just like push
backs of people not wanting to to do it
right um and yeah our management team
equally we've got an amazing leadership
team who were trying to coach people and
look after people's mental health and
that was a big thing as well as part of
the world that we live in now and trying
to look after them where they're put
into situations that they're not
comfortable to do so yeah I think people
just won't set up to do it because
they've had again it given to them on a
gold or silver or bronze platter for the
last couple of years um okay and then
did that before I want to come to
you next but guy did that show up in
your environments how do we feel about
what Alicia went through or what they
were saying at
SRT yeah if I if I um yeah completely
agree with all of that um we're we've
not traditionally been as a business
we've not traditionally been a delivery
focused business so um most of our staff
somewhere in their locker have had the
360 360 thing for them and it's kind of
like trying to undo that like a it's
like a Sleeper Cell that you've had to
reignite and uh remind them that they
have been taught this and sort of re
re-engage it so we we've we've
definitely had that challenge um it's
definitely more difficult particularly
in Tech to to find to find clients
client control is more difficult so it's
it's it's a little bit more about trying
to ignite some old training for them and
trying to re-engage that um for us but
yeah I definitely agree um I guess
let me come back to you then one of the
things that you shared with me which I
thought was quite interesting was
diversification of clients so what you
shared with me was you felt that uh this
year um you've been heavily weighted or
typically you've been heavily weighted
on the companies that you acquire being
like sort of smmes um so something will
go on to next year but like that sort of
impacted you because the investment in
these certain companies dried out which
meant they weren't hiring or they were
turning off the tax more quickly quickly
so you recognize that a lot of your
client portfolio was in that space and
you're thinking about how can we get
some of these bigger clients that may
not feel some of those things yeah so
it's it's kind of like the the flip side
of the benefit we have of being
predominantly a 360 business that I've
just talked about um that's great but as
a result of that we had a a big portion
of our I'm talking Tech specifically
here are the smmes and the smmes are
great because you can you can open the
door with them get in just at the time
they've sealed series a funding or
whatever it is and then youve ride the
coattails of them for you know they've
got 50 developer vacancies whatever it
may be I'm certainly not filling them
but
um so I'm told um and um and and you can
ride those coils and it's really really
good in the boom time but so much of
thatn tech Market is reliant on Market
confidence and funding and so on so when
that dries up you can find find yourself
a little bit more exposed and I think we
found that this year so that's a that's
a learn is you know when the when the
market was going great last year you
know just ignored it you didn't care
where the deals were coming from you're
just doing doing placements celebrating
posting it on LinkedIn and like everyone
does not me but everyone else um and um
but but the but you you don't really you
don't really analyze what's going well
and you don't you know if I if I'd have
sat there last year and gone let's look
at the diversification of our climate
portfolio every everyone laugh but we
should have looked at the diers because
because when that funding dries up in
that sort of space we were a little bit
more exposed than we would have liked to
have been so bit of a lesson learned I
don't know if we could have done
anything about it but I think I think
that's uh that's something that we
spotted this uh this year um so guy let
me come to you on this I think Alicia
you might have Shar this with me but I
feel like guy we spoke about you know
what does uh the recruit of today look
like what do the traits that we want to
hide for these things so I think
something that you all shared it might
have been you actually Alicia sorry
but guy what do you think of this the I
think and ala both said that they
found it hard managing people that
entered the recruitment industry in 2122
maybe almost had like a bit of a full
start because of you know the quick
success that they were um experiencing
and then this year has been tough and
like managing that like how's that
showing up for you guys how have you and
your leadership team you know helped
people understand that yeah maybe you
may not be um successful this year but
comparing yourself to last year it
probably isn't a wise or smart thing to
do I've adopted the phrase It's the
hardest way to make an easy living like
to literally telling people it's a
job so and people still keep coming
through the door so it can't be that bad
but from my perspective I think we've
always had that routine of Business
Development so you can come in and pick
it up and get on with it so when we're
hiring people now we're looking for
people with personality a little bit of
life experience if you've had no jobs
and you're coming in in 18 you're going
to struggle trying to connect with
people trying to be on the phone and
make money and and try and get people to
buy into you so trying to solve what
sort of people we're looking for and
where they come from you want them to
have some life experience you want them
to care and want to be laser focused on
what they want out of the job like my
business is a vehicle for everyone to
get what they want out of it like I I'll
take a bit along the way but largely
they come in to get what they want so
people that can really articulate their
goals where they want to get to and have
the life experience to talize that and
go forward and then willing to accept
it's the hardest way to make an easy
living I'm going to if you come into my
business you're going to hate me right
because you could have 10 our jobs on
and I'm going to tell you to pick up the
phone and do some more business
development but guy I got 10 jobs yeah
all right they'll be gone tomorrow get
on the next ones right pick up the phone
do another 100 dials get some more jobs
on keep your stuff fresh and hot that's
old school mentality and as much as that
might have you might have had a softer
Landing in 2019 2020 2019 was a a
terrible Landing by the way 2020 also
it was 2021 that was slightly
better so so the people in your business
that were with you in 21 2022 who are
now struggling how have you helped them
how have you like helped them understand
luckily for my team they're not
particularly struggling because we we
kept that solid two hours a day Business
Development so it wasn't a case of
getting out your sword again and going
back to battle it was like cool you've
done this every day you know what to do
now you got to up it up up up it a
little bit I've actually taken on a kind
of key account management approach so
the most senior people in the business
which is slightly more 180 than maybe
most would like but they're still 360
Consultants will go out and and build
the relationship and then they've got to
build the the relationships under so
we'll take it the relationship at a
senior level and then the Consultants
kind of have to build their own micro
relationships but they've got the PSL
they're on the suppliers list and
they're making sure that our Consultants
can still add value so they can still
talk about the industry they can still
put passion into their words and that
they still have a personality but
they've practiced it every day for the
last years you saying is you you you
feel like you guys didn't get complacent
with business development which a lot of
people did as much as they hate me yeah
you've got 10 jobs on go get 10 more all
right okay so you just really drilled
that never never stopped Fair N I feel
like you sh was it you that shared that
with me I feel like in terms of like
managing people that sounds like
something I
probably so like how how's that shown up
for you guys because obviously you know
you've seen a lot of different markets
the Peaks and yeah I I think I think
listen yeah it's definitely shown up I
think I've I've got quite a I'm going to
go on a ramble now but I've got quite a
take on this which is I I think think
we're really privileged in recruitment I
think I think we've got an absolute
privilege of a job okay because you
don't need qualifications you don't need
to have gone to University you don't
need you don't have to pass exams and in
front of you you've got a career where
you can earn extremely good money you
can rocket your career progression if
you want to start your own business you
can do so without much Capital without
much barrier to entry so I think I think
when you're in a leadership position
it's important to to try and give that
context for people who are having a
tough time now obviously if they've got
difficult you know circumstances we're
struggling to pay bills it's not going
to help them to tell them get over it
but but but I do think it's important
that you that you you give them the
context that they've got I I just think
I I every day I think I'm really lucky
to be in recruitment so everyone
stumbles into it right no one goes I'm
I'm going to grow up and be a
recruitment consultant um and I'm really
really lucky so when it is do you know
what when it is a tough a time when it
is you haven't hit your quarterly you
haven't hit your monthly you blanked or
whatever whatever that scenario is for
you I think it's important as a if
you're leading a business to try and
make sure it's okay for people do you
saw I mean make sure make sure that you
remind yeah go go and tell a Frontline
nurse how difficult you're having it
because because you didn't hit your
commission you yeah you get pretty
humbled quite quickly wouldn't you so I
mean I think it's important to make sure
it's okay for people people who did come
into that 21 22 sort of environment it's
still real for them right they're still
hitting things so you've still got to be
real to them but also bit of arm around
the shoulder it's it's not going to be
like this forever um there's some
markets that are absolutely flying if
you're in Tech it's a tough year but in
in the grand scheme of things it'll be
all right you'll be forgetting about in
a year's time okay nice and
drum so Alicia let me com to you on this
more of like a lesson that you guys took
at sr2 this year which was um you shared
with me how you really uh felt like you
did a good job of investing in your
contractor care and the back office
infrastructure do you want to just tell
us a bit about that cuz you felt you
were quite passionate telling me about
that in terms of the amount of money
that they saved you you reduce the time
it took you guys to get paid Etc so do
you want to tell us a bit about why that
was a bit of a lesson for you guys this
year yeah and I think Chris doesn't mind
me saying but we we set ourselves a
business at the Target this year of 11
million and we're probably going to hit
six um and we set up the business and
definitely the back office to be an 11
million pound business which we're not
going to be this year so we did invest
really heavily into our Ops Team and I
think a lot of people forget about back
office um and just such a huge part that
it plays in terms of invoicing and
contractor care like our contractors
are get they their customer service is
exceptional and in terms of the money
that we've saved with our contractor
invoices and um all the interest that
we're not paying in terms of our um
financing it's it's massive but we
definitely did invest really heavily
into that thinking that would' be 11
million pound business and we're not so
we're just tweaking it to make sure that
they're adding value in the back office
for people that aren't bringing in
actual money um but I think it's
something that's forgotten about
massively but equally we're at a
business now where we're I think we're
like 70 heads I forget we're either 65
70 um that we've obviously we're at that
time to have a back office whereas some
of the micro businesses are doing it
themselves but it's something massively
to think about and to invest in um quite
early doors because customers do speak
about it and it does make you stand out
from the crowd more than I think that
you think about so Ju Just quick one
then just quickly um so intended
obviously the plan for Castle was to be
11 so yeah I think you know when I
interview a lot of uh business owners
sometimes they wait until like things
break to then fix it rather than what
you're saying is let's get the systems
in place so we can grow into being an 11
million business so when when did that
investment start out interest was it 12
months before you hope to be 11 was it
18 months was it 24 months cuz that
might be helpful for people yeah I think
it was probably the start of 2021 so I
don't what May 18 months or 18 months or
so ago now um is when we really invested
invested in it and and got serious about
everything and also we were expanding in
terms of EU and and us and so we needed
to be a real sort of professional
business terms of that back office in
terms of moving Banks to move into a
global bank rather than that West that's
just the UK for example so it's little
things that that that that you don't
think about we didn't do any of that we
no but I endorse it because I think um
we've always been a sales force sales
first business and it's Salesforce we
don't do any Salesforce um should do
more um we've always been a sales first
business and we've always invested in
the sales primarily and you know the
back offic has gradually caught up uh I
think in 22 we completely overstretched
it um and as a result of that we we we
nearly got into a real panic mode of you
know we've got we've got you know loads
of money owed to us that we can't
collect and all that sort of thing so um
do what Alicia said not what wish you
invested in that earlier yeah I think we
should have I think we stretched it too
far we should have looked at it maybe
end of 21 instead 22 we were we were
there you know just sticking in loads of
deals which is great um until your
systems your functions behind it can't
catch up so we learned that the tough
way this year can I chip in for the
startups yeah get it start with the end
in mind like if you are setting out to
build a business that's 10 20 50 60
people don't don't like bodge it don't
pick a a CRM that won't support you
don't pick a factorer that's going to do
a crap job like check your references
check who who've worked with good people
because I've spent probably the better
part of the last six years hating a
factoring company or hating a CRM or
finding a way to bodge something
together that didn't work together so if
anyone's like on that precipice or
starting out an early doors three of you
or whatever pick your stuff right use
the stuff maybe it's more expensive to
get the stuff that everyone else is
using at the top but invest heavily at
the beginning if you can afford to
because changing stuff later down the
line like from itus to ballhorn is is a
is a nightmare don't do it it's all
right so do just on that this was
actually um all feel free to I'll
come to you first but this was actually
a question from Chris I think it's a
good time to ask ask it so his question
was scaling the operational parts of the
business in what order to build those
out and when to do them so he broke it
down HR ta L andd Finance marketing so
if you're with you know with that frame
that you just said guy I want to be you
know 20 person 30 person company when
should I think about hate Char when
should I think about ta at What stages
do you think Finance first okay Finance
first get your get your money in then
look at Human Resources then look at
business
operations and I think finally look at
Talent acquisition I think a business
operations is something that I my old
business op I was here like I didn't
know anything about it didn't have a
clue hi Tom didn't have a clue and I was
like cool this guy's a wizard and he
looked at business he was a business
analyst and systems and that was vital
but you think Talent first but as a
recruiter I know half the room right so
you can go and recruit recruiters that's
that's what you do you're a recruiter
get your Finance right day one like as
soon as possible Finance then you look
at yeah uh HR then you look at systems
then go to internal any disagreements
there or were just yeah again we didn't
do any of that um we um we were like I
said a sales first business all the
investment for the first 10 years was
probably in sales and it always felt so
yeah that's probably what you should do
but we we um we focused a lot on on
sales so our we did have Finance Finance
I agree with I think the only different
take I'd put on that it depends on your
model we've always been quite a trainy
dominant model Therefore your L&D
function gets a light sha on it a lot
quicker if you're gonna go down that
model if that's not your model then L&D
you can probably put to the back of the
queue behind some other stuff um so I
can't yeah yeah I can't we we were very
sales dominant and everything else was
playing catchup and like I say last year
we probably stretched that too far um so
yeah it's probably different um do what
guy does not no no I I I stacked up my
my L&D person's here that we took at 20
heads which was before we got a finance
person so I missed L&D off that list so
quick uh quick one and then we'll move
on to thinking about next year um I
think Alicia and Nigel I both said to
you if you was in the um audience
tonight what question would you WR like
what would you love us to talk about so
Nigel you said I'd be really interested
to hear other people's perspective on
like what industries were hot or like
where people opportunity is so for you
you said to me like Renewables for you
guys grew 20% this year so do you want
to tell us a bit about um this might
mean that people want to go into the
Renewables industry but like let's just
talk about where where have you seen
pockets of opportunity this year where
there being real growth so the the story
one of the big lessons that came out of
this year for us I think people
naturally talk about negative things
when they're talking about lessons one
of the big lessons that came out about
us was um making big bold decisions
because five years ago we made the
conscious decision to turn off the T we
were doing loads of business in oil and
gas we had a 100 Grand a week contract
book uh a load of top billers a good
team in it and we five years ago we
decided that didn't fit with our ether
acid didn't fit with our values to be
making money out of oil and gas uh so we
completely pivoted it um and that's
tough that that's really big when you've
got a load of top billers imagine just
going around to them one Monday and S
saying we're not going to do what you do
anymore um there was some collateral
with it but I think yeah as in I don't
think any of them are still
here this was supposed to be a positive
lesson was it hang on so okay no no but
jok inside the um so I think the lesson
was we made a big old decision then and
now as a result of that this year I
think we're five years ahead in
Renewables lots of people looking to get
into it and there's still plenty to go
around but I felt we were really well
positioned because of a you know a
difficult bold decision five years ago
um and yeah we've got a presence in UK
which mostly does into Europe um um
we've got a presence in Sydney doing it
we've got a presence in the US doing it
and in different parts of the world
there's different types of Renewables
obviously in the US there's a lot more
solar than there is in the UK for
example uh wind offshore wind is big in
Europe uh and Sydney is solar and solar
and wind as well so these These are
really good markets to be in um and I
think you know for all the mistakes
we've made we we're we're reaping the
benefits of a big bold tough managerial
decision five years ago um but it's a
really good space and there like if
anyone's thinking about going into it
there's still plenty to go around you
know it's not you yeah M you don't own
the market mate no no we don't yeah if
you could check with me first you go
into it you're all sales mate so I'm not
I mean everyone's on the phone doing
deals
yeah it's a really uh it's a really big
market and if you look at the if you
look at the sort of government pledges
in every part of the world to spend on
Renewables it's not going to disappear
yeah so but I think we're reaping the
benefits of a tough decision five years
ago to be in the market and we've got a
decent presence there nice no I
appreciate you sharing that Alicia any
pockets of tech that's been hot this
year or
no um again like there's a lot of
companies that have Diversified and
opened additional Brands within the
renewable space predominantly that we've
seen and again as said earlier we've
very much stuck in our lane we set up a
brand that was completely different to
anyone else I know a lot of recruitment
companies say they're different and I
think we've made our stamp that we are
different in terms of social
responsibility becoming a b our profit
donation um and all our USPS and our
initiatives that we do so we've really
used those to win um we're still
probably our contract books by 75%
public sector and that's something that
we're still massively invested in in
terms of actual real Partnerships bid
work um using borp helping companies
improve their ESG scores um is something
that we're really passionate about um
and equally on the other side 75% of
contract book in public sector is
something to maybe have a bit of a
squeaky bum about because if yeah that
all gets shut off tomorrow so we are
equally working to diversify more so in
in the private sector as well but
there's no real Market I think that's
doing better than others in in my
opinion in Tech um specifically
everyone's a specialist um I'm not I'm a
generalist but um I think just stick to
what you're good at don't panic and
we're just going to continue to keep
doing what we're doing and be number one
okay so let's look ahead then guys um
thanks for sharing that so let's um
let's look ahead then before we do some
um live Q&A so I think guy let me come
to you first on this I think something
that you shared with me I think I'm
pretty sure it's an atomic habits um
quote which I feel like every recruit is
R if they do a book club which I mean
it's a banging book to be fair but you
said fall to the base of your system so
what are your you know what your system
so for you you really thinking about
next year is all about getting more out
of less really imp um you investing in
your systems tell us a bit about you
know what you mean by that and what
those systems look like and what you're
thinking about uh well we're still
startup culture so our business systems
are so building building from like
where I am today we've got some really
deeply ingrained habits that are going
to help us right but I I'm I said this
earli it's an unpopular opinion I I I
still want people on the phone for three
hours a day so I want to do all the
other smart stuff around it right so you
guys we're talking about not hot markets
or hot markets any Market's hot if you
add value but what value does your
Market require at time you you offer it
right and how many of these recruiters
having a difficult time have gone
straight to the Bargain Basement rates
and said actually we do cheaper rather
than hold the line or find a way to to
reinvest in value so across all of my
businesses we're reinvesting in
marketing we're reinvesting in how we
can influence our customers and how we
can invest back in our customers the
phrase is give a little get a lot right
so if I can train all of our recruiters
to have better knowledge to invest in
the sectors that they represent and give
back brilliant and and and on the
systems piece is making sure that
everyone understands their position it's
a chess board a business is a chess
board as far as I can see you got people
that play different roles different
responsibilities and as long as everyone
knows the systems that they are and the
part of the business that they run and
they become bulletproof in that and that
system runs every time time and time
again which anyone who works here for me
knows that that's not how the business
is today but that's the investment that
we're making is that everything is
mapped and everything works and that's
going to take a while for sure so what
we talking about here like so if
someone's going to take a job we've got
a talented way of doing it there's some
of can go find out how to do that those
types of things yeah it's partly
training it's partly like the commercial
brain right so how many of the business
develop recruits that can't business
develop know that when you can go and
get reference that's a sales call who
who still does that right I mean it's a
10-year-old trick if you work in
construction give me some references
I've got some jobs so like who's still
doing that commercial element who knows
that the person that's just been pulled
out of that job is a job for someone
else to fill in another Market who's
backfilling like these commercial
systems as well as learning development
systems as well as the other training
elements there are so many systems but
everyone needs to know which ones work
your habits are basically a business
system so creating the right habits in
the recruiters that creates the the
right business okay and then Alicia for
you top of Mind was um building that BD
culture that BD mindset so are you going
to make everyone get on the phone for 3
hours a day what's your approach how you
how you going to do it no because I
think it's not one siiz fits all in
recruitment every Market's different
every personality is different
everyone's sales differently Put Me 3
hours on the phone I just won't do it
because that's not I'm an inbound sales
but again I've built my brand for the
last 10 years to be to be able to do
that personally so no I think it's yeah
it's allowing people to do something
that works for them um and we're not
going to suddenly 10 times multiply our
kpis that we again we don't have kpis we
have everyone has an annual Target we
work backwards in terms of how people
going to hit that
monthly how they're going to hit it
quarterly and how they're going to hear
it annually and we help them to do that
so they have they have copy eyes yeah
they
definitely in terms of they have sucess
metric they know what they
need have kpi come it reverse
engineering reverse engineering reverse
enger okay we'll call it we'll call it
that but no but but equally I do think
look phone wins and so many people that
you speak to nowadays they're like oh my
God someone's called me and you're like
yeah of course but there's so many
different Avenues to do doing
recruitment think about what like do you
think about any non-negotiables like sr2
BD culture what are some of the
non-negotiables if any I'm just trying
to work hard 100% stand out from the
crowd like again using USPS but equally
there's a lot of like disingenuousness
in our in our Mar in our industry as a
whole there's a lot of sorry to call you
out there's a lot of white privileged
men speaking about that they care about
diversity okay if you care about that
like genuinely care about it like you've
got to do your research you can't just
suddenly be like Oh I'm G to suddenly
start a women in Tech podcast when you
don't really give a you just want
to try and get money or try and get some
clients on so you've got to be genuine
in terms of the things that you're
speaking about and I think that's one
thing that we've got as consultants is
people really care about not diversity
at all and I'm not saying that Andy
sorry just to pick you out that Andy
massively cares about increasing
diversity in Tech he doesn't but he
massively cares about adding a huge
amount of value to his clients and being
the best that he can be so it's not
saying Andy these are your kpis that you
need to do I mean it's buity manager he
doesn't he just makes everyone else
happy um and does an amazing job but um
yeah I think going back it's it's
indirect selling um and just adding real
genuine value into the market that's not
just bashing the Fe n for you because
obviously you guys are sales machines
that's we're not thinking about that but
for you no for you you said to me like
where you feel like you've missed a
trick or you know cross the team
holistically like you're good at opening
the door getting the first two three
placements in but then throw your out
for that okay yeah okay yeah fair so one
you know get that F get that first deal
done onto the next client whatever but
we've got um you're thinking about
increasing the client spend how can we
increase the amount of deals placements
are doing with our clients how are you
thinking about that ex exactly that we
um we we as a business we we're better
at The Hunting than the farming is is
the the way of looking at it and we've
got a lot of people who because we do
the vertical Market thing they look into
their vertical Market they open doors
but they don't necessarily look sideways
so a lot of our our new BD strategy if
you like for next year will be about
what can we get out of our clients that
we've opened the door with and then just
walked out the door so how how are you
going about how are you thinking about
that I think I think we need to set up
our people um I think when you want to
change shift a mindset of a business and
so on you have to reflect it everything
right down to the commissions right down
to the um to the targets and so on and
because our business has always been set
up for to be new business it's not
necessarily there so you know it's great
having an inherent 360 mindset that's
really really good but when you miss
opportunity so I think we need to look
at how people are set up what their jobs
are and how it's how it's sort of paid
because at the moment it's mostly 360
pay and we we don't um we don't have a
particularly great model for um for
making making sure people are rewarded
for passing stuff sideways and so I can
be quite specific on this this is this
is an action that we tangibly took so
we've created a key account management
role so it's land and expand right so
one person takes the relationship which
is business risk for startups and
whatever one person takes that
relationship and then they it's their
job to get the other eight Specialists
that can service that client introduced
to the right people so they sit say at
HR level or they sit at procurement
level whatever they they've got the
relationship with the client they can
control the information but then they do
the recommendations so you need someone
in this sector recommended and then
eventually you m that entire client and
it's all sit in one single place and you
reward those key account managers for
the job that they do so how they how are
they incentivized on the amount of money
that they spend or like how's that show
my age a little bit here we we we still
use like a whiteboard metric that's made
up it's a fugazi it's like whatever the
average value is whatever but they're
incentivized on new business deals right
so anything they've Rewritten not on
what's existing so they instead every
new business deal they do they'll get a
percentage of that okay so I think this
would be a good time to ask this then
and then we'll bring in some Q&A um in a
sec but um uh Tom asked this on this
topic which I think is interesting so
have you gu do you guys use any client
retention incentives for example
discounts for repeat business donations
to charity Etc if so what do they look
like and how important has that been for
you this year or maybe thinking about
next year any of that made it into your
strategies on how can we incentivize
doing more business with existing
clients I spent £10,000 on drills at the
end of last that's a joke the world
drills drills why would you do that so
quite a lot of our clients are
construction and Engineering Educators
yeah so as part of a a retention
strategy I I literally £10,000 p on
world drill sub slightly devastated by
it I I got a gift card and everything um
but in in the sense of that like it was
what little thing can you do a spread
I've got I've got 300 390 odd clients in
education yeah so what can I spread
that's reasonably affordable like I
can't send them like a bottle of wine or
anything it doesn't help so I sent
drills and toolkits for attendant so I
sent out at early in the start of the
year and said at the end of your year
give this out to your students and but
there's loads of other bits and pieces
that we did that was about value ad like
free CPD events putting on uh free
subscriptions to stuff like that uh some
other exciting bits actually just
showing up to the client and then
offering them anything you can offer
them to say thanks for working with us
like what is it you actually want you
don't want a bottle of wine that's like
six quid or whatever what is it that
will say thank you for giving us the
business and asking them and then they
they came out asking for cash quite a
lot of the time I'll be honest really
which was a little bit sore at points
you went and bought £10,000 of drills 10
grand drills and about I spent about
another 15 grand on sponsoring their end
of year rewards and stuff like that but
that works and you get the marketing
although another my marketing team
showed up thanks guys but um we you get
the stuff that goes a long way find okay
cool massively and they remember it to
the next year no you got any client
incentives in place mate no I've just
got
a no we're not as I said uh as I said I
think we need to look at how we
incentivize that but we're
we alici what about you then cuz I've
seen um I've seen companies who like for
every placement they do with the company
that company then technically donates X
to like a charity for example have you
played around with this sort of stuff um
well we give five% of our profits
charity and our clients obviously
contribute towards that because that's
how it happens and we send a newsletter
every single quarter to every single
client that we placed with in terms of
everything that we've achieved that
month whether it's we rock interviews
whether it's how many trees we've
planted how much money's been donated
and actually tell them this is how much
money you contributed to our charity of
choice this year because you working
with us and it's just a relationship
thing right our our clients work with us
because we have amazing relationships
say we don't then give a discount if you
do a second higher a third higher we do
our donations and and that's what we do
but equally I do think there's a lot
again in Recruitment and I know there
was a post Once Upon a Time on LinkedIn
actually not so long ago about inviting
head of talents or or female leaders to
like football days rugby days golf days
like women in in Talent female CTO
female leaders don't want to do that so
it is thinking outside the box if you're
going to go and reward them and and do
something different um but yeah we don't
do anything in terms of that sort of
incentive apart from our charity
donation take them out have
relationships have fun and have like a
real genuine value ad that we can that
we can do in terms of yeah wi Rock
technology volunteers and other the fun
stuff we do and do a great job by the it
right that's the and yeah not too bad so
um we're going to come to Q&A in a sec
then so I'm going to introduce this Tech
tour in a sec okay so there might be
some issues but as we're about to do
that um let's just end on Nigel
prediction for next year like what you
know if we're sitting down this time
next year what talk to me about you know
what you think the market would have
experienced like just give us anything
that you're thinking about going into
next year yeah so um I think uh We've
started to see in Tech a little bit you
know we've just come off the best our
best whiteboard month of the year and
things like that so there's little sign
showing but then it's been like that all
year then it's disappeared again so
always one deals
M so it's like um so I think
listen we've got two very different
stories in our business one is the tech
side one's the Renewables side there's
no there's no sign that Renewables is
going to stop we can't hire people into
it quick enough we can't fill our
clients roles that's that's going to be
fine and that will continue to fly
I think the um what we're seeing in Tech
is the it's a bit like that it's been
stop start all year um but there's just
a few signs you know the metrics are
pointing in the right direction we do
use kpis I love kpis um the jobs
interviews and so on are going in the
right direction we haven't quite seen it
converting as we'd like yet but there's
certainly signs there so I think on the
tech side we that Tech hasn't
disappeared right you're about to use
some we're going about try and use some
tech it's every you can do anything
without some tech so the the the need
for Tech hasn't disappeared in the world
just the confidence around the market
and the investment in it might have
might have slowed up for a little bit so
for us it's all about keeping ourselves
positioned well so that when it goes
again we're we're ready to go again I'm
pretty sure we are nice Anisha what's
top of mind on into next year for you I
think contract's going to win okay um in
my opinion from lots of conversations
have just got Co to sort of yeah
expanded in America and and they say
that one in 10 people at the moment are
Contracting in the US and by 2027 one in
five people are going to be contracting
in the US and the US is huge honestly to
map it out it's very shiny very exciting
um but I think contract's going to win
um and again similar to what n said but
we're not going to diversify in terms of
our brand just yet we're going to stick
to what we're really good at and this
month I mean I think our best month this
year was February randomly um and yeah
every single month we go it's going to
be the month we're going to have a
banger we're going to have a banger
again and we're not there like we're
very steady every other month um but I
do think from from what ni said again
similar we the pipeline is is big for
for the rest of this year and I think
that everyone's going to be hopefully a
lot happier going into 2024 but I do
think the contract is going to be the
winner of 2024 go I can't really because
I'm not in Tech I can't really Mo I just
have to go yeah it be all right I think
be right for Tech but um from my
perspective if you do the Bas Bic really
well you build really good relationships
you work really hard then we're going to
have a great year for for me and my
businesses we're going to have a
tremendous Year we're we're tracking a
record year and everything's going to be
great but I think that's because we've
done the basics so well and we continue
to do the basics well and don't get
cocky like really simple it's it's the
market will chop your legs out the
market will be a difficult place if you
if you don't stay on your product
continue to enhance it continue to offer
value and give something back you you're
going to find difficult periods and it's
going to get more and more challenging
as long as you continue the process of
doing your best and offering the best
value you should be fine nice so what
we're going to do now then uh Matt if
you could so basically the way this tool
works is if you scan that QR code you're
going to be able to ask a question the
cool thing about it is it's entirely
Anonymous now I can moderate the
question so yeah that's got that's got
disaster so but if I I can moderate the
question so if any of not be showing it
so if any of you go proper literally
laugh all way through this every single
thing that someone said he's laugh so if
you if any of you that want to ask a
question scan that I've already got some
questions that a lot of you submitted um
so if you scan that but Matt if you go
on to the the ne next slide I've already
got some um questions up and then we can
start going through some so which one
have I got here so the biggest challenge
in
gr yeah Okay cool so let let's start
this one no I'm coming to you in this
one I know this is a big part of um your
model right so let me just read out for
you yeah so what do you see as the
single biggest challenge when growing a
recruitment business specifically with
homegrown grads and what would be your
solution talk to us a bit about that I
was shy to read it and Alicia just read
grads got it seriously um so the biggest
shot yeah we've been a um look graduate
churn okay in a good in a good um in a
good market we've had our churn below
30% which is pretty good in a not such
good Market it goes to 50s and 60s so I
think you have to accept that and you
have to have a plan for how that looks
what I see sometimes is if if you're if
you're going to employ grads and if
you're going to take people into who are
new into the industry you have to
absolutely red carpet their experience
for the
first four 8 12 16 weeks whatever it may
be uh and I mean serious investment in L
&d and if You' if you've had an
experience where your grads aren't
sticking um or your trainees aren't
sticking then i' have you actually sat
through your induction process are you
actually happy with how that is have you
sat through it yourself and is it is it
the red carpet it needs to be and are
you absolutely sure what good looks like
what are you expecting from these people
after two weeks four weeks six weeks
eight weeks because I I think the the
generation coming into the workplace get
a bad rep um I think it's I think it's
grossly unfair I think most of them
actually want to do really well I think
it's your job to show them and
demonstrate to them and give them the
Journey of what they need to do well so
so Ju Just on that cuz I think it' be
helpful what are the op op's
expectations then like I really like
that mindset of um guys help me
are like yeah the red carpet experience
I love that how can we make you know
this first what like the expectations at
those Master typically I'm definitely
not the right person to ask specific
metrics but what I would say is that
we've got um we invest heavily and
review it all the time a uh what
training they do on what day and then
what they once they've learned it
whether it be in the um in the classroom
whether it be digitally whether it be
online it's a mixture of all of them
there's real clear sort of right you're
now going to go on the sales floor and
then the sales manager is really bought
into what they need to do they'll have a
task to complete they either complete it
or they don't regular sort of review
points so I couldn't tell you the the um
because I didn't take my own advice and
sit through it recently um but the but
it's really really clear and every sales
manager knows right my trainy is on day
three that means they'll be learning
this today I need to do this with them
afterwards now there's only certain
aspects of the recruitment life cycle so
it can be in whatever order you pick but
i i we get off asked this question quite
a lot because we're quite a well-known
predominantly grab model and I I see so
so many people will sort of do a halfast
attempt of L andd or they'll they'll dip
in and dip out or they'll they'll learn
something in that with their L &d
function that they've invested in then
that's they go out to the sales floor
their sales manager tells them something
completely different sort of thing so
it's a real takes a village thing to get
the training model right and then still
be okay with maybe losing the odd one or
two or three four yeah all right cool
well let's go through some of these
because we got to be out of here in like
10 to 15 minutes so um I'm going to come
on this one so can you see that now yeah
nice so um Alicia talk to me what is the
most popular incentive benefit apart
from kamish that gets the most traction
positive pressure from your people
volunteer
days
uh unlimited Holiday unlimited holiday
uh like some people take like crazy
amounts and then we have to force the
others I'd probably
say people love hea which we what was
that sorry hea so we give like 30 quid a
month or or 50 for operations for them
to buy whatever they want every single
month whether it's contributing towards
uh I don't know their gym membership or
hello fresh boxes or buy what's he sorry
so it's a platform for people like and
they can spend it on a bunch they spend
on something that they actually want and
it gets used every single month and I
think a lot of things don't get used
when it comes to sort of benefit
packages um but that's something that's
used every single month for people and
again it's not forcing something down
their throat it's something that they
can they can choose themselves so that's
a big win and people do love
volunteering days I too go personalized
incentives person what they want
like trainers should I go with trainers
if they make a I don't know sometimes
add 50 candidates into the system in
their first week we incentivize them
with a pair of shoes but ask them ask
them what they want custom incentive
custom Target so you want to hit a
particular thing so say you want three
days off but you want you have to do it
in a certain way set the parameters
there's obviously standardized we have a
standard commission structure standard
salaries but whatever people want and
and benefits like the good benefits like
paying for the gym membership and stuff
they kind of forget about them but
they're there and then they're reminded
oh yeah I need to use that but they
they definitely like being addressed as
an individual and then set and then
trapped and then measured against it but
don't certain stive then forget to
measure it like I do like now have you
experimented with anything seeing
anything better than the the 360 Commish
no just 360 no no no we've um we've
actually we we we have been we haven't
got in a platform like he he hi hi uh
but we we've always been quite good at
those sort of spoke um tailored you know
what does this individual want based on
your your sort of goals hit a milestone
and do it so yeah I'd agree with guy on
that we've we've always implemented that
okay nice um right let me just pick out
uh one of these so Guy questions
specifically for you my friend uh
similar to you in bashing the phone um
always driving BS development and have
been over for 10 years how do you bring
your newer Consultants from 2022 2023
into driving the new BD and AKA picking
up the phone so do you just can't teach
it just except some people won't have
that confidence to to speak to anyone
about anything right so use your chatter
boxes first send them out to fight and
they could get cold but like put people
out and and train them and invest in
them one of the things that I'm working
on at the minute is how you share
information and how you you warm them up
to Business Development I've got to go
from here straight to Manchester to
stand in front of 75 HR directors as
part of our BD strategy right I've got
to go out and and kind of petrify myself
they're slightly less scary than you lot
but stand there and and it's never
something I've I've not done it before
it's new on the list so what can I do to
get my team involved in that so face
Toof face meeting I'll bring up eight
members of my Manchester office they'
have to meet HR people in the flesh and
be petrified so warm them up get them
into conversations bring them into teams
meetings when you're meetings with
meeting with clients like show them that
the client isn't as scary as you think
they are that they actually want to
spend money with you they want to work
with you so give them industry and
knowledge give them industry expertise
work with them and show them it's not as
scary and when they get rejected build
them back up again send back out to
fight but don't accept oh I've made 100
calls and no one no one's picked up it's
like well make another 100 or get the
phone and pick up the next one right
that was the tip in the first day call
the next person I promise you it'll be a
good phone call okay um I'm going to
show this one Alicia you shared a bit on
this what does this look like for
you guys what impact has 2023 had on
your retention
coaching
that um uh main reason for churn main
reason for churn um we this is going to
be I'm not doing a good job of selling I
am I let me say uh the downside of when
we train people and we we invest in them
heavily is that we lose a lot of people
who got to start their own business and
and that's been true this year um and
that is well how how many do you Reon uh
I can think of across the group at least
six or seven who've done that this year
um does it like does it get like easier
each time or is it bit every time it
hurts when you keep talking about it no
no no it's um no it's it's it's it's a
sort of mixed thing because on some
normally by this stage normally by this
stage they've done a good five or six
years of you they've been really good
people they've they've you know they've
they've build loads of money they've had
a really good impact so you're like in a
weird way you're kind of proud that they
feel you know whatever you've taught
them is sent them off to to feel
confident enough to do it but it still
it still hurts no one likes using losing
big big personality some big billers
sort things so yeah that's that's
probably the the one that we struggle
with and then Alicia I think you please
feel free to correct me but I think you
said obviously clearly very passionate
about the amount of women in your
business the diversity in your business
and you've lost the most amount of women
this year right yeah most of them
traveling oh is that yeah most of them
traveling um I think again coid they had
plans in coid Co happened it's a tough
year and and they decided to to do that
again the for some of them red carpet is
fully rolled out for them to come back
um some of them not um but yeah
traveling's definitely probably been the
biggest thing a couple of people have
left and started their own business and
yeah not copying anything sr2 related of
course um but yeah the main main thing
and a couple of people left joined
another recruitment company asked to
come back left on bad terms um but yeah
traveling's been the biggest thing um
and and then like just just curious like
is that now something you actually like
try and find out if people have plans to
do that when you interview them um I
don't know I don't have we have we asked
that question recently I was thought you
might now we are we are we are plans
over the next years to be fair like
we've only just we we're we're very much
an experienced model in terms of that so
um yeah it's like we've got a couple of
Juniors that are absolutely like one of
them will blow your mind they're
unbelievable but they're not going
traveling time soon but yeah it's
definitely a concern their passport yeah
yeah you have to hand it you have to
hand it in um but I don't I don't
interview anyone anymore I don't whoever
we do ask it but I'm sure we do um n to
come to you on this one I feel like
surely you thought a lot about this top
three things you would all individually
look for in a traine what are opposes
non-negotiables when it comes to um some
display of business Acumen um as in you
know whenever we interview them can they
they piece together bits of information
to try and get to something can they
find you know have they got that sort of
inquisitive nature that makes them ask
the right questions to get to it because
that would translate well into business
um are they are they coachable and
teachable um are they receptive are they
receptive to critique um and we'll do
that in interview we'll challenge them
get them to defend their stance on
something and so on because that that
shows a sort of a bit of a bravery and
some broad shoulders that means that
when they're being trained on something
they don't take it personally and then
just the hard work thing that they've
got to have displayed at some point in
their life that they've got themselves
out of a comfort zone so yeah those S
Alicia I feel like that's not really I
was just going to
say really your model is it work hard be
accountable if they're a good human and
this is this is probably really bad to
say but I love a chav oh wow like I love
a CH
recruiter yeah like someone who comes in
he's just going to like I don't care and
just go for it
um wow like someone who like you tell
them that no but like you're hir on the
basis of your chadness I knew I was
going to get like don't say that but
someone who's like just like Rough and
Ready around the edges and just gonna
absolutely just go for it yeah I mean
that that is that's going to be a bad
clip that is going to be that is going
to be a bad clip oh my god um but yeah
so like someone who's just like a bit
rough and ready around the edges um
who's just going to go for it and like
just haven't got any
fear
recruited love that um guy over to you
and then I'm so basic on this just got
yeah what your nonnegotiable you just
got to work hard this is a job and
if you just have to put it in right you
have to put in the effort and then I
look for someone that gives a if
you actually give a and we can see
you care that's so important to us
because we all care so deeply that we
want want you to love it as much as we
love it and I love recruitment I mean I
don't particularly love any particular
industry but I love recruitment I love
the industry that I'm in and then you
got to be resilient because you're going
to get punched in the face 100 times a
day because I've got you on the phone
100 times a day and it will be I'm not
saying I'm going to hit you just putting
out there for the h job ODS but if you
employ CHS it will be yeah it's going
get bad get your Burber on but um n you
got you got to be resilient this job is
honestly some days are terrible and
other days are amazing and and 51% of my
days are better than the 49% that are
bad so You' got to be hardworking and
resilient um right so before before we
finish um thanks everyone for being good
sports I think you know these guys have
been nothing short of honest I think so
we appreciate it so let's let's give a
hand to these guys for
sure um yeah so yeah just again like a
huge thanks to all of you uh for coming
hopefully you really enjoyed it I look
forward to getting feedback um we have
hired a couple of tables at a place
called steam I think is that a place
cool right they're definitely isn't an
open bar we're not you know we're not
doing that well but um if you want to
come there after more than welcome but
um thank you all for coming really
enjoyed you know being uh in Bristol uh
appreciate the support and yeah just I
guess just large round of applause for
these guys thank
you